Avengers: Endgame didn't simply hit the Disney+
content shelves like the hundreds of other
previously released, Disney-owned movies did.
On the contrary, it showed up on the new streaming
service with a few added delights.
Here's all the never-before-seen Endgame footage
revealed by Disney+.
The death of Black Widow was one of Endgame's
most tragic moments.
Watching Widow and her fellow hero Hawkeye
engage in an emotional tug-of-war over who
would sacrifice themselves to obtain the Soul
Stone was heartbreaking enough, but witnessing
Widow jump off that cliff and tell Hawkeye
to let her go was devastating.
But it could have gone down a bit differently:
the deleted scenes available on Disney+ reveal
never-before-seen footage of Black Widow getting
shot by Thanos' Chitauri minions, who arrive
on Vormir and begin firing at her and Hawkeye.
As she's running toward the cliff's edge,
Black Widow suffers several wounds, including
one to the torso that leaves her crawling
across the ground.
In the end, she manages to turn around and
shoot an enemy who was about to kill Hawkeye,
then sacrifices herself as she does in the
standard cut of Endgame.
A less-intense and unfinished deleted Endgame
scene bundled with Disney+ centers around
designing the silvery Quantum Realm suits
the heroes use during their time travel missions.
In the scene, we watch as Tony Stark walks
into an area at Avengers HQ where Professor
Hulk is outfitting a crude CGI mannequin of
some sort.
Iron Man inquires about the status of the
"thingamajigger," then admires how the Quantum
suit design blends technology made by Hank
Pym with "Stark styling" and a "noggin bubble"
courtesy of Nebula and her space-faring friends,
or, as Tony calls them,
"'Rings of Uranus?'
What's your troupe called?"
"The Guardians of the Galaxy."
When Professor Hulk states that someone will
have to test out the Quantum Realm suit, Ant-Man
says "not it!" before Hawkeye steps into the
scene and offers to take the suit for a spin.
On Disney+, fans can also find two deleted
Endgame scenes focused on Bruce Banner and
The Ancient One, the leader of the Masters
of the Mystic Arts who explains to Banner
how messing with the Infinity Stones can alter
reality if they aren't returned to the exact
moment in time from which they were taken.
One sequence shows Hulk meeting with the Ancient
One, who's relaxing with a drink in her hand
and a pair of sunglasses on her face.
In this cut, she explains to Hulk that he's
"five years too early," and that Doctor Strange
has no knowledge of the Time Stone for which
Hulk and the Avengers are searching.
The deleted scene ends with Hulk asking who
the Ancient One is.
The second deleted scene is an alternate take
of the time travel explanation sequence.
Here, the Ancient One is speaking with Hulk
instead of Bruce Banner - evidence that she
didn't knock Banner's soul out of Professor
Hulk's body to better connect with him in
conversation.
The discussion goes mostly the same as the
one seen in the theatrical cut of Endgame,
but the deleted scene included on Disney+
features the Ancient One admitting that she
was aware of Thanos' potential for destruction
but didn't do anything about it, since taking
precautions with Thanos could have altered
something else in the universe.
"Easy-peasy lemon squeezy."
"You're a very interesting person."
"It's quite a burden."
Another never-before-seen Endgame moment revealed
on Disney+ is a scrapped scene that shows
Earth's Mightiest Heroes assembling in the
trenches during the epic battle against Thanos.
As directors Joe and Anthony Russo explain
on the commentary track, the sequence was
meant to be a "building block" for the climax
of Endgame, but the Russos would up abandoning
the idea for a variety of reasons - namely
that the moment was missing narrative substance
and wasn't all that interesting.
An off-shoot of this idea, the Russos note,
was to have this pep talk in the Mirror Dimension
- the parallel dimension in which practitioners
of magic can do things outside the public
eye.
"Easy-peasy lemon squeezy!"
The final additional scene snipped from Endgame
that's loaded onto Disney+ centers around
Tony Stark in the moments after snaps his
fingers, defeats Thanos and his army, saves
the universe, and sacrifices himself for the
greater good.
Post-snap, he's transported to what Joe and
Anthony Russo refer to as "The Way Station"
- the metaphysical location where Thanos himself
went after he killed his adopted daughter
Gamora to obtain the Soul Stone in Infinity
War.
There, Tony meets a grown-up version of his
daughter, Morgan, played by 13 Reasons Why
actress Katherine Langford.
At first, he doesn't recognize the young woman
he's speaking to - but when Morgan quips that
the two of them are "pretty close," Tony realizes
she's the same person who often told him she
"loved him 3,000" as a child.
Morgan explains that her father's sacrifice
worked, that she got to live and grow up and
be happy.
When Tony admits that he's scared he "made
a mistake," Morgan says she understands, but
she's very proud of him.
She also assures her father that she's okay
without him:
"I'm strong, like Mom.
And I'm happy.
I'm happy we had the time that we did, and
that you were there for me - until you couldn't
be."
Of course, the scene wraps up the way all
scenes between Tony and Morgan Stark should:
"I love you 3,000."
According to the Russos, the "Tony in the
afterlife" scene didn't make it into Endgame
because it "felt like it ground the movie
to a halt."
It saved audiences a ton of tears as well,
but you didn't need the Russos to tell you
that.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.